so this is the movie that Jim Carrey and
Sean Penn walked away from and now I
know why the Three Stooges
right so the Three Stooges is a movie
based off of the Three Stooges TV show
from the 1930s it involves Larry Curly
and Moe don't forget about Shemp Larry
Curly and Moe and they go on shenanigans
and they act like idiots and slap each
other around and you know comedy really
slapstick comedy for the old show that
is the movie I wouldn't call it comedy I
sweat grew up a big Three Stooges fan I
loved these guys I was a kid I would
watch him I would laugh it was a good
time I spent the beginning of this movie
I was like I really hope the rest of
this movie is not this bad and hey I saw
the rest of the movie and it was that
bad it was depressing as hell I have to
assume that either the Three Stooges
show was this shitty also or the movie
just missed the mark entirely I'm gonna
go ahead and say the movie missed the
mark entirely I mean the one really
impressive thing about this movie is the
fact that the guys that they got to be
the Three Stooges sound exactly how the
Three Stooges sounded in the TV show if
that is a positive it is the positive I
mean it had all the makings on paper to
be the Three Stooges movie that would do
the Three Stooges justice had three guys
who sounded like The Three Stooges they
acted like The Three Stooges but it all
just fell completely flat read one it's
90 minutes long that's probably not a
positive for the premise mean the Three
Stooges are funny in moderation give me
an episode that's a feminist long
slapstick you'll laugh a little bit then
it's over but a 90-minute long movie
that is too much man that is overkill I
know that from the trailer everyone was
pissed that Snooki was in the movie I
mean the fact that smoking the Jersey
Shore Cruise in this movie is like the
last thing that's wrong with it in fact
that was the most entertaining part of
the movie I mean seeing most slap around
and berate the crew of the Jersey Shore
yeah that made me chuckle so I got to
say that was the funniest part of the
movie to my everlasting shame it was the
funniest part of the movie and it did
have some nostalgic moments like you
know the Three Stooges theme kicks on
and it fades in between scenes like the
show did but again it had the formula
and the patterns down but all of the
jokes just fell flat it's like the movie
was written and executed by someone or
two people we just don't know what funny
is anymore Ida point in this movie I
almost got up to leave but I was like no
I'll stick around till the end and I'm
glad I did when the end credits came up
model
posing as the Farrelly Brothers came
on-screen they were like oh remember
kids the mallets we use they're fakes
either rubber so be sure to play safe at
home we are trained professionals here
don't do this at home I just I don't
know why it rubbed me the wrong way I
just hated the fact that they had to do
that because if you remember there was a
time you know last month where you could
show a movie like this and not have a
public service announcement after the
movie going hey kids play safe out there
I mean I was a kid growing up on the
Three Stooges and I knew you couldn't
smack someone with a mallet or rip a
chainsaw across their head or they would
die I suppose I knew that because I had
parents who you know parented maybe
that's why kids are stupid nowadays
because parents just suck sorry parents
out there you're failing these days oh
that's right I don't just review movies
I review life is the Three Stooges dog
dude it is the best thing I've seen
since Jack and Jill The Three Stooges
definitely is dog all right so your
least favorite Farrelly Brothers movie
what is it comment below let me know and
as always you can like what you've seen
here and you want to see more click
right here to see more
[Music]